Italy remains under a nationwide
lockdown and the effects of social
distancing are playing to see Rome's
Piazza del Popolo the people's square
all but deserted empty canals also in
Venice normally overrun by tourists the
streets of Venice are now being
decontaminated in Bulgaria as elsewhere
people are lining up to stock up on
supplies should they have to isolate
themselves but in many supermarkets
shelves are bare in Spain the government
is set to declare a 2-week state of
emergency and announce increased
measures to control the kovat 19
outbreak already famous tourist sites
like Barcelona's landmark Sagrada
família Basilica have been closed off
France has also ordered closures of
cultural and tourist attractions both
the Eiffel Tower and the Louvre Museum
are closed to the public but for the
city's few remaining tourists at least
one typical Parisian attraction remained
open the Moulin Rouge was opened for
business Friday night but only to
celebrate its last night before -
closing its doors Monday schools will be
closed so we'll stay at home I have
three children so I'll work from home
starting Monday I think tonight we'll
have a good night because it's the last
Germany is also wrapping up its defenses
closing schools and many public
facilities and as of Tuesday Berlin's
world-famous nightlife will grind to a
halt as bars and clubs will also be
closed
many of the clubs don't know how they're
going to survive the loss of business
the closures will bring we've never
experienced such a big threat to the
cultural scene it's possible that by the
end of this crisis a large part of the
culture for which Berlin is known and
thanks to which many people feel good in
Berlin will disappear
while many of Europe's main cultural
attractions are funded by taxpayer money
Berlin's clubs are funded by their
patrons who are now staying at home all
right joining me now in studio a Lima
Hatake from DW sports to look at how
this pandemic is affecting the sports
world starting here in Germany the
Bundesliga finally deciding to suspend
the season but it took them a while to
make that choice right I think the
German league I think for the long time
they were just hoping that hey as long
as no players of fact that no coach is
affected then no harm you know they
don't have the coronavirus we can
continue playing and unfortunately
viruses don't work that way and we also
and then of course they were really ski
on keen on this idea of guys - fela
which we know if it goes games and
that's because you have stadiums without
any spectators and it does feel kind of
eerie a bit creepy even at times and and
then what happened was that information
emerged yes yesterday before Friday's
Bundesliga game that perhaps one of the
coaches paddleboards coach Matt was
showing Crona like symptoms and that's
when the moon Zika panicked and he
decided to cancel off cancel the games
but at the same time people also need to
understand that what made that the
corona virus has really turned the
football world upside down really on its
head because in order to plan next
season you really have to sort out this
season's or things like
relegation/promotion the european places
so it's a real struggle for football
right now dealing with this I mean given
that struggle how our players reacting
how our fans reacting to this decision
that's actually one really nice positive
it's very refreshing a lot of the fans a
lot of the players there seem to be
really accepting of it they understand
that football isn't everything that it
can be put on the back burner and that
right now the number one priority is
people's well-being and it's about
containing this coronavirus well a lot
of speculation as well about the fate of
this year's Summer Olympics in Japan
here's what the Japanese Prime Minister
had to say on the topic earlier today we
will continue to closely cooperate with
IOC and of course IOC is working closely
with WH o as for us we would like to
overcome the spread of the infection and
hold the Olympics as planned
yeah so for now the Olympics going ahead
as planned
according to Shinzo obby but I mean so
many major events announcing either
cancellations or postponements really
the Olympics is starting to look like an
outlier here it is and I can't help but
shake my head at what he just said I
mean it seems to me that he's in a state
of that Japanese government is almost in
a state of denial and there's also an
element of wishful thinking and I get it
from their perspective obviously the
government pumped billions of dollars
into these games and if they lose them
if they cancel then they will be in the
- but at the same time it's a huge risk
hosting these games led allowing them
because you're putting lives at risk
you're asking you are asking hundreds
and thousands of fans and athletes to
come to Japan literally around the world
yes yeah and that's how disease spreads
that's how illness is spread that's like
exactly what happened with the corona
virus so I don't think it's really a
smart idea idea to put people's lives at
risk and they are right now also a lot
of options ideas emerging and everything
and one of them is for example just like
we had with football is that let's hold
these events let's have these Olympics
but behind closed doors but of course we
also learned from the NBA and from
football that athletes are not immune to
the virus and always work exactly can
hit everybody and then of course the one
idea that the Tokyo organisers seem to
be very open to right now is perhaps
postponing it but I would not rule out a
cancellation because it has happened
before during World War Two of course
right well these are games scheduled to
start in late July at least for now
Alima hotaki DW sports thank you